These are some of the competing paintings, such as:
Gerard David's painting "The Judgment of Cambyses"
Hieronymus Boss of Hell (*) * (*): A painting made up of three sections called "Garden of Land Lilies"
Henry Fossley's painting: "The Nightmare"
Edvard Monk's painting: "Cry."
But there is only one panel that really scared me,
These are.
Francisco Joya's painting: "Saturn devours his son"
What you see now the Spanish artist imagines the giant Cronos
He is devouring one of his sons according to a prophecy that he will give birth to one of his offspring who is raping his king as he did to his father.
Every time his wife gives birth to Rhea, a son is eaten by Kronos, so that the prophecy can not be fulfilled.
Unfortunately for him, Ria conspired against him and hid their son Ghar, Zeus
Who in turn fulfilled the prophecy, denied his father, and ended the rule of the Giants.
This tale, a famous Greek legend, but look at how Joya portrayed.
Some notable paradoxes are obvious at first sight.
In the beginning, Cronos devours his children by swallowing them at once, according to legend.
In fact, they are still alive in his stomach. The Joya plate here, more sinister.
Here he was inspired by the Flamenco artist Rubens, who in turn painted the same legend as well.
Saturn, painted by Rubens seems to absorb the life of his child, even with this atrocity,
Robbins depicts drama, vitality, and beauty as well, characterized by the baroque style that made him known in turn.
At Joya, that beauty is nil.
We stay with the crazy monster panicked.
As if he had been discovered in the middle of the darkness by a mobile phone carrying a torch, entered the wrong cave.
Saturn, the name of the Roman Crowns, has already finished taking off a small head,
His black mouth wraps around the elbow of his left hand in preparation for his leg from his joint.
And its rectangular body curved in a strange position,
His hands digging in the spine,
Blood is flowing down the arm, neck and shoulder of his son, in a frighteningly basic color.
Looking closely, we will notice that this body is not a child at all.
But it is one of the bodies of adult Saturnians.
There is something more shocking in our knowledge that the victim knew what was happening to her and her failed attempt to survive.
But the real horror - I think - lies in when and where the painting was discovered.
In the end of his life, Francisco Goya bought a house on the outskirts of Madrid, nicknamed "La Quinta del Sordo"
Or villa deaf according to his former owner, and this is a strange coincidence;
Because Joya was also deaf.
His physical and mental state was in decline, and Joya painted fourteen mural, called
"Black Paintings"
Directly on the walls of his inner house.
And the painting "Saturn devours his son"?
They were in the dining room.
The pictures you see now take fifty years to come.
Joya did not refer to the paintings himself.
No one had intended to see it
But to this day, people are puzzled about the meaning of these black paintings.
Why did Joya create these pessimistic scenes in his home?
Maybe going back to his career helps us understand.
He grew up in Zaragoza, Spain. The fourth of six children in a family with a lower middle class.
He was a delightful boy, while he was a painting student in Zaragoza, Madrid and Rome.
His first serious career consisted of his ornate decoration; to decorate palaces and luxury houses in the city.
These spaces are inspired by
"Rococo Style"
Elegant, comic, and nice, taken from the lives of nobles and peasants, they enjoy their daily endeavors.
Joya eventually became the painter of King Charles IV, a hopeless king
Unlike his father, Charles III who was loved by the public; for he proceeded and began to attend
Enlightened secular values ​​of Spain.
In 1793, Joya was infected with an unknown disease
Caused by its design.
He was still fulfilling the requests of his royal clients, and the disease was a disastrous turning point in his life and art.
Seen in his painting "Yard With Lunatics" (*) of 1794 (*): Joya said he saw this event in mental estates in Zaragoza.
Bodies fighting and comforting from torment.
The difference between these and decorative frames
Awesome teams.
With his unhealthy reputation, Joya began to see the country around him with a clear vision of fainting in a series of seals
Los Caprichos or Freaks, making the Spanish culture a tragic debacle at the same time.
Under the shadow of Enlightenment, Joya sees the country
It retreated from the line of modernity. The king occupies a concern, people
Obsessed with superstition, so stupid that they do not realize what they want.
You can see him confuse all the mysteries of his fantasies, and run behind the detailed truth
The need for social criticism, obsession with animals and monsters.
All this is sumptuously summed up in "mind sleep awakens the monsters".
Things got worse in the following years in Spain.
Napoleon invaded the country, slaying who was objecting to his campaign.
Joya was a witness to the shedding of this blood, and this deeply hurt him.
His painting on this subject, May 3, 1808, was a revealing description
Of brutality, war and resistance.
Before this, "war" was a theatrical component in art.
Joya here only depicts cruel power. Just a passion without fake mediation.
Five years until Spain regained its throne.
During it, the resistance established a body in 1812,
It was demanding liberal reforms, such as national sovereignty, freedom of the press and free trade.
But with King Ferdinand VII gaining power, this body was destroyed immediately and he was apprehended by those who founded it.
Joya withdrew and is disappointed in
The country that in his youth was seeking a new world, but now the aristocrats swallowed it again.
He encouraged the war, became sick with illness, and began to paint nightmare scenes in the walls of his house.
In one of them, a boy is eaten by a father, prophesying his king's court on his hand.
Until now, Joya knew that this progress was uncertain, and when he was wrong, he did not make it painful
But makes it terrifying, and slow, and the victim feel it during the occurrence.
There are a lot of ways to read the "Saturn devouring his son."
Perhaps Joya was trying to expel the demons that hovered in his head, or the demons of his country.
Or perhaps he was trying to honestly portray one of the terrifying aspects of human life
Using the skills and techniques he learned, and developed throughout his life.
The "black paintings" changed the history of art, but what remains the most shocking
Is that Joya was not interested.
He does not care about our way of reading this painting, because he did not paint it for us or for anyone.
The interpretations are unable to describe the meaning of the painting "Saturn devours his son".
It is a brute force, a horror without any intermediary.
A monster watching from a dark wall in a dark room,
Mating.